it's been 13 years since hollywood
legend james cameron transported
audiences to the lush jungle world of
pandora in 2009's avatar in which humans
have colonized the moon to mine it for a
precious resource called unobtainium the
first film follows jake sully whose
consciousness is put into a synthetic
body that looks like the indigenous
population the navi and ends with jake
leading a rebellion against his
destructive employers before he
completely joins nati and her tribe
cameron has previously talked to length
about his ambitious plans for the avatar
franchise and the number of sequels are
in production but a stunning new trailer
has finally given us our first look at
the next chapter in the saga avatar the
way of water the sequel picks up over a
decade after the original movie and jake
has seemingly found peace as part of the
navi he's even started a family with
nathiri the stunning visuals show off
more of pandora this time around with
the action moving from the gorgeous
jungles to the deepest oceans obviously
this comes with new creatures for the
navy to ride across the water something
that'll definitely come in handy as they
deal with the threat of the resources
development administration the footage
doesn't reveal too much about the story
instead it focuses on the gorgeous
visual effects but let's take a look at
the small details from the first avatar
the way of water trailer to see what
they might mean for jake and nathiri one
of the biggest developments is the fact
that jake and nathiri have children
together now which isn't so surprising
since they became a couple by the end of
the first film they have a few na'vi
children but their family is definitely
non-traditional because they also have a
human child this is a little surprising
since most of the humans were banished
after the attack on the tree of souls in
the finale but according to empire the
young boy is mild spider sakura a human
who was born on the hell's gate rda base
which is where jake first arrived on
pandora unfortunately it seems like
naitiri harbors some ill feelings toward
her adopted son producer john landau
told empire jake took him in but natieri
always saw him as one of the people who
destroyed her home and killed her father
so you have all these dynamics playing
out although the human forces were
forced off the moon at the end of the
first movie humanity still seems to have
a presence on pandora with the trailer
showing off a huge base of boasts a
fleet of scorpion gunships that look
ready for battle it'll be interesting to
see how the rda has evolved in the
decades since its crippling defeat and
whether it struck some kind of peace
treaty with the indigenous population
the company is also apparently still
using its avatar program since a pair of
avatar soldiers can be seen stomping
through the jungle with rifles it seems
yadier clearly hasn't completely
repaired its relationship with the navi
since spider looks to be aiming a bow
and arrow at the two soldiers it's
possible they've held up in an easy
alliance over the years and something in
the sequel has destabilized that
relationship maybe it's the return of
colonel carriage played by stephen lang
yes the actor is reprising his role in
the sequel so it looks like the
hard-nosed soldier is getting a
resurrection of some kind the company
probably still wants to mine the moon
for its material although the company's
executives probably have a score to
settle with sully and his family for the
damage they did in the original war kate
winslet has reunited with titanic
director james cameron for the way of
water and she plays a pivotal role in
the highly anticipated sequel the
trailer only offers a small look at
winslet's character that's about one
minute into the footage during a
december 2020 appearance on the late
show with stephen colbert winslet
offered up some hints of what her
character's role will be in the
franchise that's actually a birth giving
ceremony that my character who is a
water goddess is is essentially hosting
considering a big part of the film
revolves around jake and nathery's
family it isn't so surprising that
they're in touch with someone who
conducts birth giving ceremonies
winslet's role will likely tie into the
mystical side of pandora but until more
footage is released we'll just have to
wonder
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you